I think creators are some of the dumbest
people on the planet you want to
jeopardize your whole degree you want to
jeopardize your career everything you've
built why so you can be on Tick Tock for
free we are better than you period
today's topic yeah
next year this time we're gonna lap you
a few moments later the
channel has been kicked off the YouTube
Partner program
saving children right
that was great with saving you guys is
better
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah while we're still celebrating
precious fit getting over are we
celebrating
Loki
I'm celebrating let me just do a little
two-step in my room
I drew a little fresher fit sticker on
the floor and I've been dancing on it
just like this oh look at us some high
value men
losing their here's why one I don't
feel bad for fresh and fit and two why I
think they deserve even worse sure
absolutely everyone's like oh how dare
you guys celebrate somebody being D
platformed they say that no I celebrate
people having consequences for their
actions that's what I celebrate and I'm
certainly not gonna feel bad for
somebody who tried to get a bunch of
channels removed from the platform with
their own copyright strikes if someone
tries did we all have short-term memory
or these guys knowingly hired a lawyer
just put out all of these strikes on a
bunch of different platforms knowing
they were false knowing they were false
they didn't care they wanted these
channels deleted yep right and what did
they say at the time everybody that was
talking what did they say at the time
what they say about the time they said
actions have consequences you want to
talk get hit the haters tried to
cast Over 30 plus YouTube channels made
videos like slander her name whatever it
is now they're mad that they're get
there's consequences actions bruh y'all
are not gonna be able to run around and
drag our name in the mud with you know
falsely without some kind of recourse
bro like that's just not the way the
world Works what we're going to do is
we're going to go behind the scenes get
the legal people to do it for us and
then they're going to hit you guys where
it really hurts your pockets okay you
make a hit piece on us we're going to
hit you back but legally can you ask why
these clowns tried to take down Abba and
preach with fake dmca strikes
basically uh we have a lot of people
that talk about us on internet and some
of it slander some of his defamation and
using our content in their videos and
we're like okay cool we've waited out
for a while for you to stop you're still
doing it so you know what cool now we're
gonna take legal action against you
because obviously we're talking our
character and our integrity so at that
point hey it's all fair game yeah I mean
yeah those are their words
right they never apologize for any that
stuff they never took it now they want
to cry about Free Speech there is a
matrix man like I mean I mean we've
talked about this with Andrew at length
like people don't want you guys to get
this message I think at some point there
was free speech where it was like okay
you know what see what you got to say we
won't crucify you but nowadays free
speech is kind of like is it even a
thing excuse me I didn't get their
Channel taken down I'm just watching as
karma comes back to bite you in the ass
that was your actions that you never
took accountability for and all of a
sudden now you want to be some Pariah
for free speech listen your whole
channel can go up in Flames your
building can go down I don't give a
what happens to you that's kind of like
those ladies who go around like hit me
hit me and you get smacked in the face I
don't care go ahead and around and
found out was two morons it'd be them if
that's it that's really that
it's funny it's just funny how the
people that have been crying about
accountability the most when it hits you
back but they're saving the work yeah
they're saving probably some of y'all
and they help some of y'all but they're
also doing some bad they want to say
it's about saving men right their
platforms what is having that little
cokehead of yours come on just a ramble
about Flat Earth another dumb have
to do with saving but what does Nick
Fuentes coming on talking about Jews
saying the n-word a bunch of times and
you know chopping it up with a white
supremacist have to do with saving men
everybody's always talking about like
education and stuff and they say well
the reason that the blacks Hispanics
aren't performing so well is because the
schools aren't funded the schools aren't
good there's not one reason I don't
think I think there is and the reason is
that when you look at IQ tests black
Score one full standard deviation lower
than whites and I choose an eight
do you think that it is like are you
taking talking about like a nature
versus nurture argument here yeah I'm
saying it's genetic so you believe that
life
I'm saying on average you should have
stayed in your lane and because you
didn't stay in your lane and you wanted
to walk together with people who are no
flightless and banned from every other
planet okay you ended up taking a big L
associate whoever you want but don't be
mad if other people don't want to
associate with you afterwards I.E
YouTube doesn't want anything to do with
you they banned that guy for a reason
and you want to bring him on and coz you
up having saying the n-word to a bunch
of black women that's her choice you're
free to do whatever you want free speech
don't mean that people got to associate
with you don't mean that people gotta
pay you to do that dumb what brand
okay you know forget Brent you got a job
okay you work at an office do you
honestly think you could keep your job
if after hours you got videos of you
publicly proudly walking around doing
the salute right with known white
supremacists and then you want to come
into work Pikachu face you're fired and
you want me to feel bad come on cuz I
could understand that some off work
Behavior shouldn't affect your job okay
I could understand to a degree doing the
salute well why is he talking about how
black people are inferior dumb IQ
whatever it is
your wife is probably ugly I said it yo
you gave her a ring pop and you licked
her at your wedding we should
fly her up for a weirdo hey yo we should
fire up there's a lot of people that are
talking about oh yeah you know what
they've been doing good
you know there's a there's food that has
a lot of protein like let's take chicken
breasts and it's good for your health
gotcha all right and uh and you should
have that and you know it's great if you
want to have nutrients and if you're
training and everything and stuff but if
I think a whole dookie in it it's
chicken breast and dookie okay there's a
lot of bad there's some good in there
there's some if you don't if you move
around the the dookie there's some
chicken breasts somewhere still doo-doo
I'm not eating that
so you if I serve you a plate a Parmesan
dookie chicken breast and claiming yo
there's some chicken breasts in there
you're not gonna eat it it's the same
thing that's their Channel
there's some good in there there's a
whole lot of dookie I don't even
understand why some of y'all like yeah
but they did good in this you don't even
see the bad you're able you wanna you
wanna toss the Bat Out the bat was there
the salute
hey man like I said you played yourself
yeah yeah you want you were you were
puffing your chest congratulations you
were puffing your chest louder and proud
talk about I'm on Rumble I'll do
whatever I want YouTube said word okay
well you can go beyond Rumble full time
and now you want to cry uh shaving
children that was great
uh but saving y'all was get the out
of here take all your pack your
bags grab your little plaque
congratulations on hitting a million
good luck on him too
okay all you men crying in the comment
section y'all would not show even one
ounce of Grace to a woman being accused
of doing half the that this man did
you would have dunked on her be like
Western women refuse to take
accountability may I just have
consequences welcome to a man's world
and y'all defended him to high water it
just turns out that all these red pill
losers right are gonna sip just as hard
for men if they idolize them y'all
notice we didn't cover them for a little
while why why do you think I didn't
cover these people for a long time not
to be associated
let them go make their mistakes you know
the idea that all presses good press is
a lie you know I don't even tell you
guys all these like beefs and dramas now
that we're like around one to two
million subscribers and it's not
something that you necessarily want to
be in all the time why because YouTube
just doesn't like that
and honestly it's not that important to
my platform in order to get you guys
what y'all need so why would I
jeopardize everything I'm working on the
money for my family the money for my
people for my initiatives for my
community why would I why would I
jeopardize that so I can argue with two
reasons and this is what I'm saying I
think creators are some of the dumbest
people on the planet and if they're not
dumb okay they're so ego driven right
that they think they're Untouchable and
I'm like you're on somebody else's
platform you don't have any equity in
this thing you have no rights in this
thing they can literally delete you
anytime they want what do you have to
base your ego off of that's why I be
telling folks this should get deleted at
any point if it does I'm just walking I
have no power when it comes to this
platform now sure there's probably ways
I can retain it through websites and off
platform things and little things even
going to rumble you have no equity in
the so people acting like they are
boss that's why I look at creators
sometimes and I laugh you're not
untouchable
it just takes one wrong video and
everything can get taken away so when
you're walking around big-headed puffing
out your chest looking at the rules and
laughing and spitting in the face to
everything like that right I'm looking
at you like okay we'll see how long you
last and they never last
now the deal isn't even that bad because
I'm not the boss right YouTube has a
payment system in place they have
advertisers that they work with they
follow me a check every month okay hey
I'm an employee I might be a little bit
more self-employed than a lot of other
employees but I'm an employee I don't
even pretend like it's not my place but
if you want to get those easy checks
because the checks from YouTube are
pretty easy
there are certain rules you got to
follow you don't want to follow that's
fine YouTube gets to cut you off you
don't get to cry afterwards so that's
why I say creators are some of the
dumbest dumbest people okay they really
don't understand what kind of
relationship they have with their
employer they don't have understanding
what kind of relationship they have with
the platform and yet they want to act
big chested and act like they're
Invincible because they're getting cut
big checks you're not getting cut big
checks because you're really smart you
can cut big checks because you have a
lot of following that's the only reason
those two things are not the same they
are not the same
the business Acumen of some of these
people is zero what businessman
wants to throw away his own platform so
he could go and raise his hand with
white Supreme
business and this is not even a fresh
this is just a money thing some of you
guys are going to throw away your whole
lives because your ego you want to throw
your careers away because your ego you
work as a lawyer but you want to be out
here having videos of yourself saying
the most foul things and Publishing I
see on Tick Tock why because your ego
you need to be heard saying dumb
you want to jeopardize your whole
degree you want to jeopardize
your career everything you've built why
so you can be on Tick Tock for free it's
like that that doctor not even for free
you gonna cost yourself 80 to 90 to 100
plus Caleb a year that doctor that
doctor that got that that lost her whole
life the doctor lost her whole life her
whole life license
like you understand that she cannot
practice no more because she wanted to
be on teaching she she can't practice
she gotta find another job she got to
close down her Clinic everything yeah
not only that you're costing the job of
your employees but you're done yeah for
Life yeah find yourself something else
to do
yo
if you want to be out here speaking to
men that's fine be smart about how you
do it
that's all I gotta say anything else
nope all right actions have consequences
ain't that you're one of your favorite
lines ain't that what you like to tell
these women when you bring them on their
platform and you dunking on their head
yeah yeah yeah
we'd love to see that male vulnerability
go on cry for them
let's go
should have been smarter